When creating any type of 3D mesh that's to be used with Chaos clothing, there are a few
things you need to know in order for the clothing to react better with the simulation
inside of Unreal Engine 5.
The first thing is the difference between a render mesh and a proxy mesh.
The render mesh acts as, well, what is going to be seen by the end user.
This is often going to be very highly detailed, could be double-sided, have non-uniform triangles,
there can be some pinching or something like that in the fabric, and we can see kind of
that for this cape right here taken from Echo.
There is some pinching up here where the cape would be attached.
Notice that it doesn't have uniform quadding, we have some geometry that is split in order
to give us that kind of look to the cloak that it's attached, the geometry or the cloth
kind of has these ripples in it as regular clothing would.
Now while this looks really good, the problem is that when we go to simulate this, we're
going to run into a lot of issues.
Also this mesh over here is double-sided, and it's got very high detail at the corners.
The problem again with this is that those simulated vertices will come in contact with
one another and they'll penetrate one another, and that's going to cause problems with the
simulation.
So what we want to actually do is make something called a proxy mesh, and we can see
the proxy mesh right over here on the left-hand side of our mesh.
The proxy mesh is used to put the simulation on, so we actually take our cloth simulation,
run it on the proxy mesh, and then link that proxy mesh to our render mesh.
So the render mesh is offset, but it's offset in a way that doesn't allow for that inner
penetration of the simulation particles in our clothing simulation, and what we'll
get out of this is this really highly detailed render mesh that looks like it's rendering
like real clothing, but we're not seeing a bunch of artifacting or having a lot of
issues with it.
The other thing that we need to talk about too is creating level of detail meshes or
LODs.
Now we can create these manually inside of our digital content creation, or we can
use Unreal Engine's built-in LOD tools to create, and no matter what type of cloth
you are creating, you do need to make a level of detail for it.
As it gets further and further away from the camera, we really want to reduce not only
the amount of vertices that are in it, but all of the clothing cloth settings so
that we can really make sure that when it's super far away from the camera, it's not
consuming as many resources because it doesn't need to really be simulating cloth when it's
only 16 pixels on the screen.